[Music]
just a quick update we have talked about
a little bit of golf stuff here we
talked about this uh new uh league
called live golf that is crazy dude
super super crazy fun to watch there
there goes joe joe got a bunch of golf
clubs for a dollar uniform looking like
a streets of rage enemy where from the
thrift store
i bought this at goodwill in las vegas
i need you to see this
a dollar per club because on monday it's
a dollar day sale so any
sticker that day is it's a dollar
and then
this bag
twenty dollars wait have it been on
dollar day what the [ __ ]
not containers not for containers it's
not it's different numbers it only has
two of the same club yeah
but hey not bad are those good clubs
anthony lee do you know
it's a dollar what do you expect
pro master plus
how could they not be they sound pretty
good to me is it like target [ __ ] or
costco [ __ ] promaster plus they're
they're old they're really old like
dunlop stuff yeah
but uh hey that being said like we said
live golf is this new league that
started at saudi back so they got
[ __ ] unlimited buckets of money they
got billions oh literally they have
poured billions upon billions of dollars
to invest into this thing um it's a
different format and they've been trying
to pretty much poach
all of the major tour players i know
this one and aren't they offering how
much are they paying uh phil mickelson
has been the top paid golfer in this
past year with like about 138 million
even though he's like 40 plus on all of
his games right but what whoa that was a
diss huh
yeah that was enough to know that so
he's whack now
a little bit but he's [ __ ] rich
right but what has just been confirmed
is that tiger woods was obviously
approached by live golf because you know
they said they need they need people to
move the needle they need people that
move the market but didn't he say [ __ ]
you guys so he turned down roughly 700
to 800 million brace yourself right to
join live golf oh
that's a lot bro but he does he is he
still playing golf actively though yes
he is he's still playing for sure he
just finished uh you know the masters at
st andrews but he's at the paga right
can you talk about hunger for like a
billion
so
just say yes go stop world hunger real
quick and then go back to the pga tour
doesn't he already have a billy anyway
so if he so he's one of three athletes
uh that have reached that billion dollar
mark along with michael jordan and
lebron james
and charles swoops
hey wait what are you laughing what
happened
hey magic's a billionaire
magic yeah oh yeah magically as an
athlete
as an athlete oh
but wait jordan didn't become a
billionaire now true what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
yeah julia what kind of host is this
huh julia
this entire time i'm like literally
thinking
how could i make that much money and the
only thing that popped into my head was
only fans
hey
very brave very industrious very brave
of you
but it's like [ __ ] don't no butts just
go for it if that's your passion
i don't okay look i don't know if that's
my passion tiger's not passionate about
goldberg
this man's passion is masturbation and
if he can make money on only fans
masturbating he would okay have you
started
i don't even have a only fans account
and i think i failed myself in my trope
because i like porn but i don't really
like only fans
damn i'm sorry dude what yeah that's
hard that's hard well because we're
finally having a real conversation with
joe now we're opening it up that's a
hard thing let's open up for a second
because like all right so here's the
thing man like
although
i am a pervert yeah i am also very cheap
oh
i feel like cheaper that's
that's the best kind there's so many
there's so much content out there
already it's like i i don't have a hbo
subscription i don't have a [ __ ] hulu
subscription because i have youtube
you know what i mean i could get out of
vpns i could watch these things
you know and the only thing i pay for is
a netflix account so then when it comes
to porn i have the same mentality
there's so many so many sites to stream
just cancel netflix and then subscribe
to only fan stuff no i can't get myself
to do it
think of it as market research
but you know what i think only fans
you're paying for more of an affection
you're not paying just for sex and for
me i'm against that
yeah you want these girls attention if
you're an only fans person but you don't
care about that yeah yeah is more like
intimacy like you're looking to have a
conversation all this i mean like you
could get nudes everywhere but for me
i don't want personalization i don't
want to treat them like people is what
you're saying i don't want to treat them
like people yeah i want just more like
objects i just want yeah object that
makes sense yeah i don't want to get to
know them no no i mean that's why you
gotta do only fancy what would you have
on yours photos of like dicks and [ __ ]
out there but like joe it's your dick i
know
it's special joe jessica
yeah finally at last the unveiling she's
talking from experience but it's just
dick
you know what i have to provide a good
conversation what does that mean i don't
know if you want to hear this but you're
more than just a dick dude that's just
yeah
you really think that about me
i think you'd probably do interesting
things with your dick that no one else
could do i know that people watching
this are like i really wanted to hear
about what julia wanted to do on the
only thing but i really do think we can
crack this with joe right now if you
guys will don't mind circle back if you
guys don't mind we're gonna do with joe
first like i bet you could show people
smegma and stuff like that and that'd be
interesting oh god dude
that would be or like what porn am i
watching tonight maybe that's the that's
how you start that's a good one too
right my my my or just
do your own uh
instructions porn pics dude joe's top 10
porn picks
i go past the paywall for that oh my
gosh you're just wearing your glasses
and just [ __ ] analyzing everything to
tell you what other porn to watch
joe professional porn analyst i'm
telling you everybody loves you know
compilation like a dj but like for porn
hey it's like when the it's like when
you're watching a porn and you're kind
of into it but then the camera guy
starts talking and you're like oh this
is even better with like this commentary
i love when they talk i love this a lot
of this commentary
there would be something i would remove
so every single time and this happens a
lot in early 2000's porn it's right when
the guy's about to bust they cut to his
face yeah just see the emotion the raw
like that i don't want to see a man's
[ __ ] face
while i'm trying to like synchronize my
nut at the same time because what if i
accidentally bust
and it's to his face while you're
looking at his face
that makes sense or it's a it's a shot
of his butthole you know you see that
those are really funny porn pranks to do
in porn like purposely do that cut to
something else so that right when you
bust you're looking at like [ __ ]
some like disaster that's the genre i
watch that's pretty good that's a whole
giant great and this is why i don't pay
for porn it cuts to people in a flood
[Laughter]
if you start one you you let me know how
that goes okay yeah i'll let you know
eventually uh-huh you're gonna be the
first subscriber have you thought about
it have you actually considered doing
this or are you just are you just
[ __ ] around
i don't know i feel like i feel like i
usually [ __ ] around when i mention it
but then i feel like the more i talk
about the more i'm like
intriguing there's a lot of potential in
there you know only there's a lot of
untapped potential it doesn't have to be
sexual yeah i know that's not here no
yeah yeah like cat she she doesn't show
[ __ ] she just shows feet
[Laughter]
i don't know because i'm not subscribed
but apparently
apparently she does a lot of feet stuff
i would assume it's a slippery slope
and she you know what she does she rates
dicks people send her pictures up there
oh yeah and then she goes that's about a
three
that's four or whatever and she talks
[ __ ] i hurt my feelings you know she
talks she she likes they like she has a
good system can you can you talk [ __ ]
about my dick yeah and talk about how
small it is do you feel like do you feel
like you would ever be okay with like
getting just a bunch of dick photos and
you just are honest it's just honest
reasons
you don't have to do anything you don't
have to like it you could just be like
five but you could just genuinely be
like wow i've seen a hundred days saying
that's a seven and a half yeah
i mean
i'm trying to get a house so like yeah
oh well then let's talk
yes
i think you'd blow up bro yeah your [ __ ]
would be crazy i bet you we could start
it right you want a boat with that house
take it right now and get some
subscribers right now a little pitch
real quick pitch what do wet wednesdays
wet wednesdays that's a good tack yeah i
like that and whatever that is to you
yeah
you make it your own you you take that
do whatever choose your own adventure
yeah dirty thursdays you make it wet i
don't want to make it
i think i'm just getting intimidated by
this i'm gonna get through this sax
saturdays
that's two on the nose
today
i think i think holocaust little
wednesdays
i think the the whole norm like what
everyone else does like
masturbating on camera that stuff is
like played out laid out
it's only fantastic
one of those videos you gotta be playing
mafia by yourself
as soon as i hear that little buzzer
buzz i'm like oh great you're gonna use
old-timey [ __ ]
johnson's net worth is 620 million
what does this have to do with julia's
only three
billion about golf let's talk about
julia
all right and imagine johnson's not a
billionaire i'm sorry that's what i'm
saying
620 million that's all i'm saying us
workshopping joe's and julia's only fans
that's so much better than [ __ ] golf
right now you know what i mean that's
all anthony day
[ __ ] snore dude no golf is great i'm
a fan you're not coming to the driving
range ever with us wish you never would
anyway yeah no [ __ ] way you're not
gonna get the [ __ ] driving it's on
green street i'm out see you there we
golf now we tried oh you guys try okay
we don't succeeded it very well but we
do try we try we try our you wanna go
golfing with us
except nid
i haven't been able to go i was planning
on going something happened literally
flake twice we see whoever hangs out
with us we see i'm gonna hang on
saturday i don't ever see nick outside
of the soft side even when we went to
hawaii together we never hung out we
hung out once yeah one just one day we
say friday's for the boys and nick says
i can't do it that's how it is every
time he's one of those uh social media
friends oh
that's bridger he's there for his vlog
channel
comes in blasted
just you guys and you never see him
again
you